David Boder: [In English] August 28, 1946. Geneva, at the school of the ORT. I shall try now to interview two instructors. [Unintelligible]...a good Russian name, that makes one homesick, and Mr. Joseph Freinhoffer. eh, Mrs. Borgman is, eh, Mrs. Borgman is the secretary of the, eh, place and Mr. Freinhoffer is the chief of the, eh, shop.
David Boder: [In German] Also, Herr, äh, Freinhoffer. Können Sie mal sagen, wie lange arbeiten Sie jetzt hier in der ORT Schule?
Joseph Freinhoffer: Seit Anfang Mai 1944.
David Boder: Sind Sie Schweizer, Herr Freinhoffer?
Joseph Freinhoffer: Jawohl.
David Boder: Und was war Ihre Beschäftigung, bevor Sie hier angefangen haben?
Joseph Freinhoffer: Vorher war ich an der Gewerbeschule Zürich Fachlehrer.
David Boder: Also Sie sind ein geschulter Fachlehrer?
Joseph Freinhoffer: Das heißt ein, äh, geschulter Fachmann, der sich weitergebildet hat zum Fachlehrer.
David Boder: Aha. Ist das in der Schweiz etwas Verschiedenes?
Joseph Freinhoffer: Nein, im Grunde genommen nicht. Ein Fachlehrer bildet sich aus einem guten Fachmann.
David Boder: Aha. Nun, sagen Sie mir, äh, und, äh, Frau Borgman, wie lange sind Sie mit der Schule?
[first name unknown] Borgman: Ich bin seit dem 15. August 1944 hier.
David Boder: Aha. Wie alt ist denn die Schule im Ganzen?
[first name unknown] Borgman: Die Schule hat angefangen Ende April 1944.
David Boder: Aha. Und das ist eine ORT Schule?
[first name unknown] Borgman: Ja.
David Boder: Nun, sagen Sie mal, Herr Freinhoffer, wie viel Jungen haben Sie?
Joseph Freinhoffer: Jetzt haben wir 36 Jungen.
David Boder: Ja. Waren Sie auch Lehrer, bevor Sie hergekommen sind, nicht wahr?
Joseph Freinhoffer: Das heißt ja an der Gewerbeschule Zürich.
David Boder: An der Gewerbeschule Zürich. Sagen Sie, finden Sie, welch ein Unterschied zwischen den Schülern, die Sie an der Gewerbeschule gehabt hatten, und den Jungen, die Sie hier haben?
Joseph Freinhoffer: In Sachen Fleiß kann ich nur das sagen, dass die Schu—, die, äh, die Schüler hier, die aus den, äh, Lagern gekommen sind, fleißiger sind als die ich in Zürich gehabt habe, als die Schüler, die bei ihren Eltern wohnen und, äh, in geregelten Verhältnissen aufgewachsen sind.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie aber, die Jungen waren ja, wie Sie es nennen, in ganz ungeregelten Verhältnissen. Was ist Ihre Idee, was für einen Eindruck und was für ein allgemeine Charaktereindruck sozusagen, denken Sie, hat das Konzentrationslager auf diese Jungen gemacht?
Joseph Freinhoffer: Diese Jungens finden jetzt zum größten Teil, dass sie viele Jahre verloren haben. Deshalb, äh, schauen sie, dass sie sich so schnell als möglich vorwärts arbeiten können und, äh, einen Beruf zu lernen, um freie Menschen zu werden. Um ihr Brot selbständig verdienen zu können und nicht von, äh, Organisationen weiter abhängig zu sein.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mal da, die fühlen wirklich, dass sie Zeit verloren haben?
Joseph Freinhoffer: Jawohl.
David Boder: Wie steht es mit dieser Bildung von diesen Jungen? Können die lesen, können die schreiben? Haben sie was im Lager doch gelernt?
Joseph Freinhoffer: Der Großteil von ihnen musste mit elf bis zwölf Jahren die Schule verlassen und hat seither keine theoretische Ausbildung mehr gehabt. Was die praktische Ausbildung anbelangt, so war es auch sehr [unverständlich], da sie in den Lagern nur Handlangerarbeit an Maschinen und, äh, und, äh, im Freien gemacht haben.
David Boder: Sagen Sie mir dies, äh, wie haben Sie beobachtet [unverständlich]? Die Jungen waren manche zwei, drei Jahre in Deutschland in verschiedenen Lagern. Sprechen die Jungen Deutsch?
Joseph Freinhoffer: Sie sprechen alle Deutsch aber, äh, immer schlechtes Deutsch.
David Boder: Ja.
Joseph Freinhoffer: Das heißt, man kann sich doch mit ihnen verständigen.
David Boder: Ja, aber, Sie werden das nicht richtig Deutsch nennen, nicht wahr?
Joseph Freinhoffer: Nein. Ein gutes Deutsch ist es nicht.
David Boder: Ja. Denn sehen Sie mal, wenn ein anderer junger Junge, sagen wir, zwei, drei Jahre in Deutschland wäre, dann hätte er die Sprache gelernt, nicht wahr?
Joseph Freinhoffer: Natürlich. Er hat, äh, sie hatten natürlich nur die Gelegenheit, die Sprache zu lernen, äh, weil sie eben, äh, reden mussten. Sie mussten reden können und haben es dabei gelernt. Aber dabei war ihnen natürlich niemand behilflich.
David Boder: Was sagen Sie, Frau Borgman?
[first name unknown] Borgman: Ich glaube, sie waren im Lager nur unter Juden...
David Boder: Ja?
[first name unknown] Borgman: und haben Jüdisch gesprochen. Und Jüdisch ist eigentlich ihre Heimatsprache, ob sie von Polen oder von der Tschechoslowakei oder von Rumänien kommen,...
[first name unknown] Borgman: und so hat sich daraus eine Art Jüdisch-Deutsch gebildet.
David Boder: Aha. Naja, die Kapos waren ja auch [unverständlich]. Ja, und dann, sie haben überhaupt nicht sehr viel gesprochen.
[first name unknown] Borgman: Mit den Deutschen hatten sie überhaupt nicht zu sprechen. Sie hatten nur Befehle zu bekommen und sie hatten ‚ja’ oder ‚nein’ zu antworten. Dabei kann man kein Deutsch lernen.
David Boder: Aha. Nun, sagen Sie mir dieses. Ich werde Ihnen eine Frage fragen, die ich, von die ich eigentlich die Antwort habe. Aber dennoch, äh, die Jungen, die Sie haben, [unverständlich] wie haben die ihr Fach ausgewählt? Warum sind die nach dieser Abteilung gekommen, sagen wir, oder nicht nach der Schreinerei oder so weiter?
Joseph Freinhoffer: Also, ein Großteil hat schon in Fabriken gearbeitet. In Deutschland irgendwo in den Konzentrationslagern und in Munitionsfabriken natürlich. Aber, äh, mehr als we—, mehr oder weniger als Handlanger.
David Boder: Ja.
Joseph Freinhoffer: Natürlich haben sie gesehen, äh, wie das Metall gearbeitet wird, und das hat ihnen, äh, [unverständlich] als freie Menschen arbeiten und lernen können, wird der Beruf interessant sein.
David Boder: Aha. Sind die begabt für Mechanik?
Joseph Freinhoffer: Der größte Teil ist begabt zur Mechanik. Diejenigen, die weniger genau arbeiten, die werden [unverständlich], können noch gute Schlosser werden, Bauschlosser.
David Boder: Und, äh, wie sind die Leute hier in der Schule? Ich habe gestern eine Klasse am Morgen gesehen, die letzten paar Minuten. Es war sehr interessant. Also, wie viel theoretische Bildung bekommen hier die Jungen?
Joseph Freinhoffer: An theoretischer Bildung haben die Jungen hier Zeichnen, dann Rechnen und Berufskunde. Außer der Berufskunde, die, äh, zwei Stunden ist pro Woche, haben sie die Werkstattkunde. Das heißt die, äh, Berufskunde, die gegeben wird während der Arbeit.
David Boder: Aha. Was nennen Sie Berufskunde?
Joseph Freinhoffer: Das heißt das theoretische Wissen, das, äh, mit der Arbeit im Zusammenhang steht.
David Boder: Sagen Sie aber, wenn die Jungen fertig sind, werden sie im Stande sein, eine Zeichnung zu nehmen und nach der Zeichnung eine Arbeit zu machen? Wir nennen „blueprint“ in Amerika.
Joseph Freinhoffer: Die Jungens müssen von Anfang an lernen, eine Zeichnung lesen und nach Zeichnungen arbeiten. Die kleinen, äh, die einfachsten Arbeiten des Grundlehrplanes werden diktiert und nach der Skizze wird gearbeitet.
David Boder: Sagen Sie, wenigstens am Anfang, wie haben Sie die Jungen gefunden? [unverständlich]. Waren sie friedlich, waren sie freundlich und wie sind sie jetzt?
Joseph Freinhoffer: Sie waren natürlich, je nach der Behandlung, die sie, äh, genossen haben, waren die Kinder verschieden. Es waren solche, die waren so scheu wie ein Wild. Die, äh, getrauten sich nicht, zu jemand in die Nähe zu kommen oder zu sprechen. Es waren andere, die waren etwas freier. Es war [unverständlich]. [unverständlich] das kann ich nicht sagen, dass einer war. Aber, die waren eben ganz verschieden in ihrer, äh, Freiheit der Bewegung und der Rede.
David Boder: Sagen Sie mal, sind die Jungen ehrlich?
Joseph Freinhoffer: Ich hab den Eindruck, dass sie ehrlich sind. So ich kann, ich überlass ihnen alle Werkzeuge...
David Boder: Ja.
Joseph Freinhoffer: . . . ohne eine, äh, strenge Kontrolle, die, das heißt die Kontrolle findet nur von Zeit zu Zeit statt. Und ich muss konta—, konstatieren, dass noch nichts weggekommen ist von uns und all den Werkzeugen, die in der, äh, Werkstatt vorhanden sind.
David Boder: Sind die Jungen im Allgemeinen gesund?
Joseph Freinhoffer: Man, äh, sie sind, man kann sagen ja im Allgemeinen. Aber man merkt die Folgen des Konzentrationslagers. Der eine hat dieses, der andere hat jenes. Krankheiten, die bei, äh, Jungens, die in einem normalen, in einem normalen Leben aufwachsen, nicht vorkommen oder weniger, äh, oft.
David Boder: Nun, äh, sagen Sie mal, also wenn die Jungen hier beenden, werden die hier, äh, was sein, in dieser Abteilung?
Joseph Freinhoffer: Ein Teil, die besser begabten, die werden Maschinenschlosser sein, und die anderen Bauschlosser.
David Boder: Aha.
Joseph Freinhoffer: Außerdem können beide Gruppen Schweißen lernen. Autogen und elektrisch schweißen, was ein sehr großer Vorteil ist. Für Maschinenschlosser ist es ein, äh, ein Vorteil, den sie irgendwo anders in einer anderen Lehre nicht genießen können, und für Bauschlosser ist es natürlich eine unbedingte Notwendigkeit.
David Boder: Sagen Sie, wenn solch ein Junge nach Brasilien geht oder nach Argentinien oder wo, könnte er für sich ein kleines Geschäft anfangen oder müsste er in einer Fabrik arbeiten?
Joseph Freinhoffer: Wenn ein Schüler aus der Schule kommt, dann ist er als ein junger Arbeiter, der natürlich, äh, noch nicht so selbstständig ist wie ein erfahrener Arbeiter, ein erfahrener Arbeiter, der schon einige Jahre Praxis hinter sich hat. Eine Schulausbildung im Beruf ist nicht das ganz gleiche wie eine Ausbildung in einer Werkstatt.
David Boder: Und die meisten Jungen denken, sie werden die zweieinhalb Jahre aushalten in [unverständlich], nicht wahr?
Joseph Freinhoffer: Jawohl, der größte Teil.
David Boder: Sind da welche, die aufgegeben haben, die angefangen haben und weggegangen sind?
Joseph Freinhoffer: Das war früher ziemlich oft der Fall, weil, äh, das waren noch Jungens, die ihre Eltern hatten und meistens nicht durch die, äh, Konzentrationslager gingen. Die ihre Eltern hatten hier in der Schweiz oder anderswo oder sie, äh, aufgefunden haben in der Zwischenzeit und dann mit diesen, äh, weggefahren sind nach anderen Ländern, wo die, ihre Eltern wieder eine neue Existenz aufgebaut haben. Diese Jungen, die jetzt noch da sind, die sind meistens elternlos und, äh, haben den festen Willen, einen Beruf zu lernen, um auf eigenen Füßen stehen zu können.
David Boder: Also, sagen Sie mir jetzt, Frau Borgman, was würden Sie zu dieser Unterre—, zu diesem Interview hinzufügen? Wie haben Sie mit den Jungen, kommen mit den Jungen in welcher Weise in Berührung?
[first name unknown] Borgman: Ich seh die Jungen hier in meinem Büro, wenn sie eine Verletzung haben, dann kommen sie hierher, um sich pflegen zu lassen, wenn sie irgendetwas brauchen, oder wenn sie irgendeinen Wunsch vorzutragen haben, dann kommen sie erst, zuerst zu mir, und ich mache Herrn, teile das dann Herrn Freinhoffer mit. Außerdem sehe ich die Jungs, weil ich ihnen französischen Unterricht gebe.
David Boder: Aha. Wie lernen die Französisch?
[first name unknown] Borgman: Die meisten von den Jungen sind außerordentlich begabt. Die lernen sehr schnell. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob es daran liegt, dass sie, äh, in den Lagern gelitten haben. Sie lernen sehr schnell und sie vergessen sehr schnell. Sie haben nicht mehr das Gedächtnis.
David Boder: Und sie beobachten, dass die kein Gedächtnis, kein gutes Gedächtnis haben?
[first name unknown] Borgman: Nicht alle, manche unter ihnen,...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Ja,
[first name unknown] Borgman: . . . was praktische Arbeit anbelangt.
David Boder: [unterbricht] Aber es könnte auch in anderen Schulen vorkommen, nicht wahr?
[first name unknown] Borgman: Ja, ich hab hier ja auch Jungs, die in andere Schulen gegangen sind,...
David Boder: Ja.
[first name unknown] Borgman: . . . und bei denen hab ich das nicht so festgestellt. Während diese Jungs sind speziell für praktische Arbeit besonders begabt. Es gibt Jungs, die vor vier Monaten eingetreten sind, und manche Schüler schon überholt haben, an praktischem Können.
David Boder: Ja, nun? [endet abrupt]